[Música]
ó ó ó bom dia meu nome é andré com de
cinema que começou com novos as
organizar o primeiro terex é integral em
lisboa
eu acho que algumas das pessoas que
estão hoje estamos tirando no primeiro
deles é dizer se não sair somente no
três sets ventura as alunas
então o o hotel simples assim o texas
foi organizado por mim pelo bairro
cristal e tortura sério que é do mesmo
tipo portugal é o presente é mais rico
portugal organizado ciço na formação
usual americana
vamos falar um caso não tivesse algumas
perguntas como diziam que eu estava eu
de organizar acima confiança chapa
surfamos por que razão uma conferência
porque qual é a motivação não é possível
nós estamos sendo muito bem e eu
organizar isso sem qualquer tipo de
vantagem sem fins lucrativos e o evento
foi gratuito e só conheceu as pessoas
conforme até cozinha país forma de
idéias novas e representará novos com
sites sem ter origem de 700 que temos um
caso o pixo nós temos 12 depois de uma
década de estagnação econômica quer era
preciso vai precisar voltas foi uma
semana antes das eleições e portanto
vemos também introduzir algumas destas
questões da mudança tecnológica na
agenda política
melhor do que eu se criado para explicar
a pessoa é é o vídeo foi feito em uma
entrevista pelo icce mãe
a tecnologia de ponta sustenta mais da
metade das exportações de israel um
pequeno país que conseguiu transformar
se numa superpotência da hi tech abrange
desde a nanotecnologia até a
biotecnologia passando pelas
telecomunicações andré marquet é um
engenheiro português que está em israel
para investigar a chave do sucesso
o segredo deste país situado do outro
lado do mediterrâneo como uma nação como
um pouco mais de 7 milhões de habitantes
e uma história de sete guerras têm hoje
em dia o maior número de startups depois
da califórnia o próprio país é uma
startup é normal que os custos mensais
jam certa forma empreendedora é até mais
fácil é o capital inicial
coisa que no futebol é muito difícil de
obter o modelo português de
desenvolvimento tecnológico ainda está a
inventar na conferência de lisboa
apresenta um exemplo o finlandês país
que fez a aposta certa nos telemóveis e
um exemplo israelita que em 40 anos e
apesar dos conflitos se transformou num
dos principais centros tecnológicos a
nível internacional mas parece
claramente em 2008 tem posição
perfeitamente portava as coisas não
aconteceram por causa de israel é a uma
nota de continuidade de uma política que
começou há 30 ou 40 anos e descida
continuada portanto é seria falacioso
dizer que as coisas aconteceram aqui por
acaso ou por mera é circunstâncias
aconteceram porque o vovô políticas
continuada já de algum tempo permitiram
hoje em dia é as grandes empresas
internacionais têm aqui sociedade
assim o efeito desejado
e talvez este seja um segredo
dezenas de jovens realistas considerados
nerds maluquinhos dos computadores
o rio nasce numa garagem da colônia ao
sul de tel aviv simplesmente para
criarem novas idéias
às vezes extravagante por exemplo como
fazer música com um balão controlado
pelo computador
[Música]
a loucura toda a tecnologia começa cedo
a grande pergunta é se portugal vai ter
a ambição para tomar as decisões
necessárias
o secretário é o movimento que neste
momento nós partimos de trás mas eu acho
que a história mostra-nos muitos países
partiram atrás não tem necessariamente
que ficará eternamente atrás acredito
isso é um exemplo nós estaremos com
certeza melhor se continuamos a apostar
seriamente em desenvolvimento
tecnológico em ciência e tecnologia e aí
o estado não pode ordenar os atentados
responsabilidades fundamentais
henrique cymerman s em artilharia
[Música]
a quem são as pessoas que foram ao 1º t
rex é nós tínhamos uma uma nuvem em
obras
temos ações que se inscrevessem já ser
um cara que o menor mentiu 16 os
técnicos
sou essencialmente curiosas são pessoas
que querem saber as pessoas têm a
certeza que este grupo que está
essencialmente também representativo de
pessoas curiosas querem saber mais
querem conhecer novas coisas são
empreendedoras são os jogadores assumem
riscos graças a um bis gostam tecnologia
é que criar um filho não é tanto mas
claramente o nosso foi otto foram
pessoas com uma orientação tecnológica é
mas acima de tudo somos todos muito
criativos
acreditamos que somos criativos e
queremos é ter uma visão diferente
isso foi na sala no início desse céu
tivemos sorte muito decentes e acima de
tudo uma linha dominante que a
estratégia do portal do ponto de vista
tecnológico das nossas apresentações o
terek sede as estampas exclusivas no
youtube vão sendo publicadas até o
próximo 30 dias podem consultar ou
disposta a salvar em osku ver internet
no youtube e tem acesso a pessoas como
pousada altíssimos mário silva que a
funcionar da forma como olhamos
província e contratamos o isso
nomeadamente para o transformaram se em
conta as lutas e os montar um blog que
na altura foi lá vender a campanha eu
pedi pra shipping limpa antártida e hoje
rezo espiritual está na antártida ganhou
concursos contra americanos contra os
sul-coreanos controlar a gente acha que
é é um exemplo que é que isto tem
pessoas que acreditam pessoas que dizem
que acreditam fazem que o tem que fazer
fazem tudo podem fazer o nuci pinguim em
praticamente todos os sentidos
vem cá por distinguir vezes e
e hoje está na partida conseguiu sonho
próximo internet vai ser um lugar o
porto é de 24 2 mil idéias por qual
afirma em um lugar que não pode ser só
praia exemplo a marinha em golfe tem que
ser um clube mais do que isso tente
também tem que ter um pouco de
tecnologia também tem que pensar ainda
que o grande latifúndio que é o turismo
tem como dar um carlos o curso
desenvolvimento
são essas obras a centrados em muito
centrado na universidade eu devo dizer
que tenho inspirou fazer o telex edis
não não diretamente mas não é uma frase
que ouvi foi o antónio carmo meca no
mundo foi o fundador da waves um
movimento que tem em vídeo falava do
galo escrita e falada como foi o país
podia dar a volta e como é que nós temos
nas coisas e fui premiado foi
inspiradora inicia eu falei com o artur
pois o estado falei com rui e agora
também já temos o pedro rocha viera que
está aqui
descubram pergunta coisas façam façam
obras quiserem pé viró garfo
as inscrições estão abertas sobre um
anjo mas teria até esse ponto como podem
se inscrever é nosso site é não tem
alguns destes vídeos e e também francês
pós vídeos no youtube
tenha certeza que esta vai ser uma
emoção muito muito giras horas o chão
frequentemente tese de redes e
[Aplausos]